la patience de Valérie Grenier a
finalement été payante après avoir connu
des années difficiles en raison de
blessures la skieuse de 26 ans a grimper
sur la plus haute marche du podium
samedi lors du slalom géant de
cransagora en Slovénie et je me suis
toujours dit que je voulais justement
réaliser mes rêves qui étaient justement
pas dire mais peut-être même plusieurs
et en Coupe du monde donc dans ma tête
j'allais jamais lâcher puis d'avoir
atteint ça aujourd'hui c'est fou avec
deux descentes quasi parfaites elle a
devancé l'italienne et première au
classement général du slalom
martabassino ainsi que la Slovaque
pétravellova surprenache j'ai vraiment
pas été stressante les deux descentes je
me sentais super bien j'étais très calme
je m'amusais avec mes coéquipeurs dans
le Lot en attendant puis c'est même au
départ j'étais super calme comme un mini
stress mais vraiment rien de gros
[Applaudissements]
donc sa première victoire en Coupe du
monde à son 90e départ et a maintenant
7e au classement général de la
discipline
après avoir subi une quadruple fracture
à la jambe droite en 2019 et traverser
une guérison difficile la Franc-Comte
Ariane a dû combattre les doutes qui la
ralentissait sur les pistes ça ne va
tellement fier de voir que j'ai réussi
vraiment à revenir d'une blessure comme
ça ça a vraiment été difficile puis ça a
pris du temps de faire mon retour sur la
neige
[Musique]
avec cette belle victoire Valérie
grenier devient la première canadienne
depuis 1974 a gagné un slalom en Coupe
du monde mais surtout elle prouve
qu'elle fait partie des meilleurs ici
Josiane Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]